I think if you thought it was a
spiritual exchange you would have waited
till you were married
no like that's why this is what I mean
like why like like men hear the things
we say and it doesn't match up with what
we do because it's like okay you're 32
you've been dating since you're 18 was
every guy you slept with in the last 12
years a spiritual since 28 because I
only started spiritual enough 28 so my
mindset completely true do you realize
there's like a pattern wait wait wait so
there's like a pattern so this is this
is like guys when they've dated enough
women they start to see like patterns in
our behavior and like one thing that
they found was like women tend to like
find God around the age of 28 so they
kind of like start to Rebrand so
basically like like basically it's kind
of like a red flag when you say around
28 I like found God or found the
spiritual journey because it's kind of
like okay I spent the first half of my
20s being a hoe and then now I'm not I'm
not saying a hoe but like it okay what
is a hoe statistically more than five
partners
I don't need to know